I don't sell ravines for every woman
they never had her hand laying over
there for my mother my sister Tina
Turner Rihanna
[Music]
brilliant fighter business guys I've
been watching on seven eight ten years
every night every Tuesday at the Comedy
Store you guys are gonna love them
please give it up for my friend yours
[Applause]
as I got older I realized my
brother-in-law's beating the out of
my beautiful sister so like a man I put
him aside I look him in the eye and I
tell him you know I say Dre I say now
you know you putting your hands on my
sister she continued to go back to you
right now ain't nothing more
disrespectful that were you telling a
grown man what you feeling in your heart
and soul and in the middle your
heartfelt conversation that other grown
man go look at you if you me now
sometime ladies you got to give a man
exactly what he's been dishing out in
order for him to have understanding of
the what he been doing to you but
here's the thing whatever man go to
discipline another grown man
the fight is no longer physical the
fight is spiritual and my mother told me
a nice 12 she said if you defended the
honor of your sister's God would put a
covenant over you the angels are
covenant you angels protect you the
heavens will protect you and God we're
not allowed to lose that battle because
of the spiritual biblical battles you
came out it will not look like that
point ladies and gentlemen I hope my
spirit so I know it'll be a day in time
when I must get great there's biblical
spiritual ass-whipping his body so
that's really desired to his later that
hit the fan that same systems
having a taco party and just for the
record
real niggas eat more tacos they're
Mexicans and the always been nothing
about my whole show remember this don't
y'all trust no man that eat less than
three tacos
you nibbling now I'm sitting
in the middle of the living room eat my
fish tacos I swear to God
what I seen in the kitchen it breaks my
heart to this day I see my beautiful
sister that raised me walk me to school
taught me my ABCs
my beautiful sister my brother-in-law
got my Britain stood in the corner I see
some type of Road stop it my
sister the chest as if she didn't come
from the wound of my beautiful mother
striking my beautiful sister in the eye
as if she they have brothers defend her
honor
immediately ladies and gentlemen I
disconnected from my physical world I
went into the spiritual world it was
just like my mother saying the heavens
opened up I seen my mother face appear
with a hail overhead and I heard that
biblical music go
but then angels came around let that
come to me and I got run over there to
protect my little sister I cannot walk
aggressively overtake my people ladies
and gentlemen
[Music]
rolled up or that drain
and guess what ladies and gentlemen I
was the big man he was another man and
let me tell every woman in here
something I also have reveals for every
woman they ever had her hands laid over
there but my mother my sister Tina
Turner Rihanna in an hour on the front
row the spirit of Floyd Mayweather
shuffle my body my hair all up you know
it was the size my favorite boxing glove
with all this God gave me Frankie fly
with the Hilton with these I didn't see
the head
Dre hit me so many times I thought I was
getting jumped at this way I realized
something
this Dre was gifted from
the shoulders ladies and gentlemen his
hair speed was incredible I it I don't
know let me chase truly go get your best
friend
number one rule ain't no rules I'll go
get my best friend we get to the play
location and I tell my best friend I say
I look him in the eye and he against her
dulo when I was gonna ask
me he's ready to die he had me fooled
like a movie star crip walking so I
don't give a
we get to my soup house yeah he got the
nine-millimeter I got the bust my head
good and right for you knocked up the
dough I let him in my one good eye like
no luck was on that spiritual then
the devil was in cahoots I like this one
the wicked said I said she
come to me I said whoopee whoopee well
she said whoopee whoopee whoo means
accelerate accelerate when she comes
over the door yeah personally I see that
did not exist I'm telling y'all I had
spirit on me that was so
wicked when I walked in there I swear to
God I was I was gonna shoot pictures
wedding pictures images ideas I think of
a look I got a little nephew named
little tray who look just like big tray
little Drake is bad as a I
woulda shot him twice
I take full five steps to the house my
sister back wrap her thigh around my
waist and try to wait a real nigga down
now Guto bc ever wait a real nigga was
going down but my trick hand was free
whoo I'm afraid we get a strong for the
good that is bitch nigga drag do
something I think was kind of clever he
comes with a blind side of my bad that's
the handle of a good enemies I couldn't
help but to think where is my best
friend
and the position I was a hitting my
fetal position I haven't told them to do
that is to the left of the door was the
window or the outside of the window
there was my best friend we can eat at
me if I give my handsome anyone ready to
die hit them easy back this way say
punches is phenomenal I was too much
from him but dude oh you got a good best
friend he'll bet but you had one too not
this way
blood has come up four fours he had a
wicked left hook he hit me in this ear
and knocked my hearing completely out
and make a long story short the police
came and guess who went to jail me but I
got good news I got bad news the good
news is my system was in court
to bail me out of jail how about
that the bad news is she brought Dre
with her it'll bake bad news worse the
judge put a restraining order on me to
stay away from drag and drag to stay
away from me which was a blessing to me
and my sister hit me was the information
that I would never ever forget and these
words like me would never ever defend my
sister again I looked at her with all
the compassion of my eyes and I said
what the is wrong with you
don't you know blood is thicker than
water
and what she replied me up and she
said don't you know come is thicker than
blood